This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Sound design is one of the more overlooked aspects of design, but it's so critical to our enjoyment of the world. Few sounds please me more than the satisfying move that my car doors make when I get inside my VW. My current least favorite sounds are from credit card chip readers that Blair and obnoxious warning buzz that clearly signals to normal humans that something has gone wrong, even though it actually means everything went right and it's time to remove your card. My love of sound and story is why I was excited to find the new podcast 20,000 Hertz, which tells the stories behind the most recognizable and interesting sounds.
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。声音设计是设计中最常被忽视的方面之一，但它对我们享受这个世界至关重要。没有什么声音比我坐进大众汽车时车门发出的那声厚重满意的关门声更让我愉悦的了。我目前最讨厌的声音来自信用卡芯片读卡器发出的刺耳警告蜂鸣声，这种声音明显是在向正常人类发出警报，表明出了问题，尽管它实际上意味着一切正常，你可以拔出卡了。我对声音和故事的热爱让我很高兴发现了新播客《20,000赫兹》（20,000 Hertz），它讲述了那些最具辨识度和最有趣的声音背后的故事。
And I'm pleased to present one of their episodes today. Here host Dallas Taylor tells the story behind the most famous sound in broadcasting. This is the National Broadcasting Company. For being only three tiny notes, the NBC chimes have had a colossal impact on media and culture for nearly 90 years. It was back in the late 1920s when NBC started using this for the first time to identify itself on the radio. W-E-A-F, New York. They became so iconic and so popular that they were the very first sound to ever be awarded an audio trademark.
我很荣幸今天能呈献他们的其中一期节目。节目主持人达拉斯·泰勒（Dallas Taylor）在节目中讲述了广播界最著名声音背后的故事。这里是全国广播公司（National Broadcasting Company）。仅仅三个微小的音符，NBC的钟声在近90年的时间里对媒体和文化产生了巨大的影响。早在20世纪20年代末，NBC就开始首次使用这个声音在广播中标识自己。W-E-A-F，纽约。它们变得如此标志性、如此受欢迎，以至于成为了历史上第一个被授予音频商标的声音。
And that's hard to get. Take, for example, the Harley-Davidson engine sound. After six years of litigation and challenges from other companies, they withdrew their application. Courts also denied Motorola's request to trade markets chirp, saying that, among other things, they didn't do a good enough job promoting it as an actual soundmark. Budweiser even tried to trademark the sound of an opening beer can. I think I'm going to go with the courts on this one. So there are only about 100 sounds that have actually officially become US trademarks,
而这很难获得。以哈雷戴维森发动机的声音为例。经过六年的诉讼和来自其他公司的挑战，他们撤回了申请。法院还拒绝了摩托罗拉关于将其标志性的“唧唧声”注册为商标的请求，理由是，除其他外，他们没有做好将其推广为实际声音标志的工作。百威甚至试图将打开啤酒罐的声音注册为商标。我想在这件事上我得支持法院。因此，目前只有大约100个声音正式成为了美国商标，
and most of them are incredibly iconic. No! Oh, oh, oh, you've got mail. The concept of a trademark is that it's something that's generally accepted that can't be confused with something else that you can make the case represents your product. That's Rick Greenhut. He used to work for NBC and was actually the last person to ever officially play the chimes on the NBC radio network. An audio trademark that doesn't have any lyrics in it, it's very hard to say, well, this represents my product. And the reason NBC could actually trademark that is they've been doing it for 40 years
其中大部分都极具标志性。不！哦，哦，哦，你有新邮件了。商标的概念是，它是一种被普遍接受的、不会与别的东西混淆的、能够证明它代表你的产品的标志。这是里克·格林胡特（Rick Greenhut）。他曾在NBC工作，实际上也是NBC广播网络上最后一个正式敲响钟声的人。一个没有任何歌词的音频商标，很难让人说“这代表了我的产吕”。而NBC之所以能够将它注册为商标，是因为他们已经这样做了40年
before anybody thought to trademark it. Today, whenever you think about branding, you think about the visual mark, the visual logo, but back in the 1920 mark, the visual logo. But back in the 1920s, the most powerful form of mask communication was the radio. The only way you could brand yourself would be through sound. Anybody who heard that in the 50s or 60s would instantly note was NBC. The chimes were everywhere. They were so popular that they even appeared in some pop songs. This is Anouncers Blues recorded in 1936 by Paul Whiteman and his orchestra.
在任何人想到将其注册为商标之前。今天，每当你想到品牌塑造时，你就会想到视觉标志、视觉标识，但在20世纪20年代，最强大的大众传播形式是广播。你唯一能塑造品牌的方式就是通过声音。任何在50年代或60年代听到这个声音的人都会立刻认出这是NBC。钟声无处不在。它们如此受欢迎，甚至出现在一些流行歌曲中。《播音员布鲁斯》（Announcer's Blues）于1936年由保罗·怀特曼（Paul Whiteman）和他的乐队录制。
The artist behind this next track, NBCI Love You, remains a broadcasting mystery. To understand where the Chimes came from, we have to go back nearly a century. Stations were using Chimes, Gongs, all kinds of different musical devices to create a sound signature for themselves. This is John Snyder, a radio historian. Chimes in particular would have been an easy choice due to how common they were. Dinner Chimes were often used to summon guests to the table, and it was also used to indicate the start and stop of intermission. NBC created a seven note sequence and the idea was that at the end of each program, the
下一首曲目的艺术家里克·格林胡特，NBC我爱你，仍然是一个广播界的谜团。为了理解钟声的起源，我们必须回到近一个世纪前。当时各电台都在使用钟、锣以及各种不同的音乐装置来为自己创造声音签名。这是广播历史学家约翰·斯奈德（John Snyder）。尤其是钟，由于它们很常见，会是一个容易的选择。餐钟经常用来召唤客人就座，也用来表示中场休息的开始和结束。NBC创作了一个由七个音符组成的序列，其想法是，在每个节目的最后，
announcer was at the microphone and is saying this is the national broadcasting company would strike a seven note chime sequence on a set of hand shimes that he held next to the microphone. As you could imagine, since this was being played live by the announcer, it was really hard to keep consistent. So they shortened it to three notes. Originally the three notes were CAF, which had the same sound that we know today just in a different key. Eventually, they use the notes G-E-C,
播音员站在麦克风前说“这是全国广播公司”，然后在他放在麦克风旁边的一套手摇钟上敲击七个音符的钟声序列。你可以想象，由于这是由播音员现场演奏的，要保持一致性真的很难。于是他们将其缩短为三个音符。最初的三个音符是C-A-F，其发音与我们今天所知的一样，只是调性不同。最终，他们使用了音符G-E-C，
which some people think stood for the General Electric Company. That would have been the coolest branding story, having the G-E-Cimes stand for the General Electric Company. But the truth is, General Electric didn't have much to do with NBC until later. Eventually, because it still wasn't being done uniformly on the handchimes, they went to an electronic device. I remember getting a tour of the technical facility.
有些人认为这代表通用电气公司（General Electric Company）。这将是一个最酷的品牌故事，让G-E-C钟声代表通用电气公司。但事实是，通用电气直到后来才与NBC有太多交集。最终，由于手摇钟仍然无法做到整齐划一，他们转向了电子设备。我记得曾参观过技术设施。
That's Rick Greenhead again. There was this strange thing back in the racks, and I said, what's that? And they said, it's a Chimes machine. NBC hired an electronic organ pioneer kept an Richard Ranger to build more of an automated system for playing the Chimes. Not only did the Chimes serve a branding purpose, but it also solved a really big technical
又是由里克·格林黑德讲述。机架后面有这么一个奇怪的东西，我说，那是什么？他们说，那是钟声机。NBC雇用了电子风琴先驱理查德·兰格（Richard Ranger）来建造一个更自动化的系统来演奏钟声。钟声不仅起到了品牌宣传的作用，还解决了一个非常大的技术
challenge. When they would change studios, they would be literally plugging and unplugging these patch cords, and it would make kind of clicks and pops on the air. Since we end each show with the Chimes, each studio would have a take control button and a Chimes button. When you pushed the chimes button, it would take that studio off the air under the sound of the chimes, so you didn't hear the click. Aside from its iconic cultural status,
挑战。当他们更换录音室时，他们实际上是在插拔这些跳线，这会在广播中产生各种咔哒声和爆裂声。由于我们以钟声结束每个节目，每个录音室都会有一个接管按钮和一个钟声按钮。当你按下钟声按钮时，它会在钟声中让那个录音室退出广播，这样你就听不到咔哒声了。除了其标志性的文化地位外，
the NBC Chimes also played a really important role in history. Outside of radio, the only other form of mass communication was through newspaper. There was no medium that passed news or information or entertainment to the public in real time. Again, John Snyder. And all of the people who were pioneers, they had to invent techniques that we take for granted today. It must have been a fascinating time to participate in the birth of modern electronic media. One of Radio's most important moments came during World War II.
NBC的钟声也在历史上扮演了非常重要的角色。除了广播，大众传播的唯一其他形式是通过报纸。没有任何媒介能够实时向公众传递新闻、信息或娱乐。约翰·斯奈德再次说道。所有这些先驱者，他们必须发明我们今天认为理所当然的技术。参与现代电子媒介的诞生一定是一个迷人的时代。广播最重要的时刻之一发生在二战期间。
For the first time in history, news from the front lines of work had become available to the mass public in near real time. Radio had discovered its importance as a news medium and not just an entertainment medium. During the war, NBC added a fourth chime to covertly notify announcers that important breaking news was imminent. If the normal chime was GEC, at the end of a program,
历史上第一次，来自前线的新闻几乎实时地传递给了大众。广播已经发现了它作为新闻媒介而不仅仅是娱乐媒介的重要性。战争期间，NBC增加了一个第四个钟声，以隐蔽地通知播音员即将发生重大的突发新闻。如果正常的钟声是GEC，在节目结束时，
they would play the chime GEC C. The National Broadcasting Company will continue its network service throughout the remainder of the night. And you're the important but so far, unconferent reports from overseas. This is the National Broadcasting Company. That fourth note, which probably most of the radio audience never even noticed, was a cue to the radio stations, pay attention, listen on the line between the program and be prepared for something momentous to come along. When it rings, all of us at NBC's, spring into action, wherever we may be.
他们会播放钟声GEC-C。全国广播公司将在剩余的夜晚继续其网络服务。并且你正在收听来自海外的重要但迄今为止尚未证实的报告。这里是全国广播公司。第四个音符，广播听众可能大部分甚至都没有注意到，它是对广播电台的一个提示：注意，在节目之间的线路上倾听，准备好迎接重大事件的到来。当它响起时，无论我们在哪里，NBC的所有人都会立即行动起来。
The fourth chime means to us. Call the office. Get down here. Big things are happening. During the invasion of D-Day, the NBC fourth chime was played alongside the Morse code sound for the letter V, indicating that the invasion had just begun. That extra chime, the fourth chime, means news of the greatest world importance. The fourth chime rang on D-Day, the fourth chime will ring again on V-Day, the day of victory.
第四个钟声对我们意味着：给办公室打电话，到这儿来。大事发生了。在诺曼底登陆期间，NBC的第四个钟声与字母V的摩斯密码声音一起播放，表明入侵刚刚开始。那个额外的钟声，第四个钟声，意味着具有世界最大重要性的新闻。第四个钟声在D日响起，第四个钟声将在胜利日（V-Day）再次响起。
Thankfully, the fourth chime was only played a handful of times in the history of the network. NBC was huge. All the other networks were still up and coming, so NBC commanded all the top talent. Ladies and gentlemen, from Camp HONC, California, we bring you a man who peddled here all the way from Hollywood on the rear end of a tandem bicycle, Jack Benny! People who were getting the ratings and the people were the next day's water cooler conversation, that would be the radio show from NBC the night before. So NBC, to me, always had seemed like a Cadillac brand. It was a brand whose name you remembered, whose logo you could picture,
谢天谢地，在网络的历史中，第四个钟声只播放了寥寥数次。NBC非常庞大。所有其他网络都还在发展中，因此NBC拥有所有的顶级人才。女士们先生们，来自加利福尼亚州坎普洪克，我们为您带来一个人，他一路从好莱坞骑着一辆双人自行车的后座来到这里，杰克·本尼！那些获得收视率的人以及成为第二天茶余饭后谈资的人，将是前一天晚上来自NBC的广播节目。所以对我来说，NBC似乎永远是一个凯迪拉克级别的品牌。这是一个其名字让你铭记、其标志你能想象的品牌，
and when you heard the sound, you pictured the logo. When you saw the logo, you saw the logo you heard the sound in your mind. The NBC Chimes, at least on the radio, came to a close in the late 1980s. When Rick Green Hut played them for the last time on the 9 o'clock news. We typically would chime out of every network feed we did. And at about 8.45, the news casters already in the booth, the producer sitting next to me. I've got the commercials in the machines for each of the time zones, and the General Manager comes up. And he said, I wanted you to be the first to know that the radio network has been sold. General Electric acquired NBC Radio through the purchase of RCA.
当你听到声音时，你脑海中就会浮现出标志。当你看到标志时，你脑海中就会听到声音。NBC的钟声，至少在广播中，在20世纪80年代末画上了句号。当时里克·格林胡特在9点钟的新闻中最后一次演奏了它们。我们通常会在我们做的每一个网络信号中用钟声结束。在大约8点45分，新闻主播已经坐在播音室里，制作人坐在我旁边。我把各个时区的广告带放进机器里，总经理走了过来。他说，我想让你成为第一个知道的人，广播网络已经被卖掉了。通用电气通过收购RCA收购了NBC广播电台。
This meant that NBC Radio no longer operated as its own entity. The NBC Chimes were not part of the sale because they're the NBC Chimes and the TV network is keeping those. Nine o'clock hour comes, we do the network newscast, and at 905-30, the newscaster says, Gary Nunn, NBC News, New York, I played the Chimes. I then pulled that tape cartridge out of the machine where I'd played it.
这意味着NBC广播电台不再作为一个独立的实体运营。NBC的钟声不是出售的一部分，因为它们是NBC的钟声，电视网将保留它们。9点钟的时间到了，我们做网络新闻广播，在9点05分30秒，新闻主播说：加里·纳恩（Gary Nunn），NBC新闻，纽约，我播放了钟声。然后我把那个磁带盒从我播放它的机器里抽出来。
Well, no sooner I had done that the general manager shows up and he just looked at me and he said, make sure no one else can do that. I did that by taking that tape cartridge home and it's sitting on my shelf. The NBC Radio Network came to a close, but obviously the chimes still live on through promos and special programming and news, but this sound is bigger than Comcast or NBC or General Electric.
我刚做完这些，总经理就出现了，他看着我，说：确保没有其他人能再做这件事。我是通过把那个磁带盒带回家并把它放在书架上来做到这一点的。NBC广播网络走到了尽头，但很明显，钟声仍然通过宣传片、特别节目和新闻继续生存着，但这个声音比康卡斯特、NBC或通用电气都要宏大。
It's something that's deeply embedded and weaved through our history, through the good, an amazing little boy who gently, through the bad, one month after the massacre, through the most important moments of our collective lives together. This sound has been with us for almost 90 years. It started as a sound that just fixed a small problem, but has become something that's completely ingrained in our culture. 20,000 Hurtz is a production of De facto Sound, you can find it at 20k.org or wherever
它是深深嵌入并交织在我们历史中的东西，经历了美好，一个温柔的小男孩，经历了糟糕，大屠杀一个月后，经历了我们集体生活中最重要的时刻。这个声音已经陪伴了我们近90年。它最初是一个只是为了解决一个小问题的声音，但已经成为完全融入我们文化的东西。《20,000赫兹》是De facto Sound的制作，你可以在20k.org或你获取播客的任何地方找到它。
you get podcasts. This episode was produced by Carolyn McCulley, Sam Sneebley, Colin Navarney, Miland Fitzwater Barrows, and Dallas Taylor, sound design and mix by Colin Navarney, special thanks to Rick Greenhott and John Snyder. 99% of visible is a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars or the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too.
本期节目由卡洛琳·麦卡利（Carolyn McCulley）、萨姆·斯内布利（Sam Sneebley）、科林·纳瓦尼（Colin Navarney）、米兰德·菲茨沃特·巴罗斯（Miland Fitzwater Barrows）和达拉斯·泰勒（Dallas Taylor）制作，声音设计和混音由科林·纳瓦尼完成，特别感谢里克·格林霍特和约翰·斯奈德。《99% Invisible》是旧金山91.7K ALW的项目，在美丽加州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。在美丽、繁华的加州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我，账号是Roman Mars，或者@节目，账号是99PI org。我们也在Instagram和Tumblr上。
But in addition to all the episodes you've heard, there is a treasure trove of design stories at 99PI.org. Music Radio to Beauty from PRX Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但除了你听过的所有节目外，99PI.org上还有一个设计故事的宝库。音乐来自PRX的Music Radio to Beauty。谢谢。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。